noi siamo
veloci
ragazzi benvenuti al podcast feroci sono
guglielmo scilla sono in compagnia di
lollo barolo michele bravi effetto
ragazzi oggi siamo la nostra nona
puntata oggi ci facciamo una chiacchiera
una persona che si è fatto due anni 8
ari ppa quindi parleremo di droga
parleremo
più improvvisamente la voce parleremo di
roba abbastanza forte ma soprattutto
parleremo anche dell'occasione di
rinascere perché questa persona è
riuscita a cambiare improvvisamente la
propria vita da spacciatore a influencer
con noi avremo ospite massimiliano
minocci conosciuti da molti come il
brasiliano all apple ha perso un occhio
in una rissa ma dice che all'altro è
andata peggio lo chiamano il brasiliano
perché era bravo a giocare a calcio non
perché sia di rio non ha peli sulla
lingua non si fa problemi a dire che
pippava 5 grammi al giorno ma adesso con
il suo lavoro del fluence air dà da
mangiare a quattro famiglie ha scontato
la pena di 3 anni e 8 mesi per
estorsione e rapina oltraggio a pubblico
ufficiale spaccio e cavalli di ritorno
messo in strada a spacciare dei suoi
genitori da piccolo possiamo affermare
con sicurezza che è stato lanciato in
mezzo ai lupi e ne sei uscito capobranco
non tollera i bulli protegge i deboli il
suo percorso sul web riaperto la mente
nei confronti di chi è diverso da lui
questo qui ragazzi è il brasiliano in
pochissime parole quindi dire a questo
punto di farlo entrare di partire a
bomba vai let's go nome d'arte air
brasiliano io sono affascinato da questa
scelta ero molto bravo giocare a calcio
quindi essendo molto tecnico tic tac i
vallesi a una volta stavo palleggiando è
un mio amico che è morto di overdose
poverino io rido perché quasi tutti sono
morti ha detto ovest e brasiliano ero
piccolissimo già avevo tv 11 anni da
quel giorno mi hanno chiamato tutti al
brasiliano tu dici una cosa molto forte
quando parli di te è tipo da bambino e
del fatto che comunque molti 2 michetti
alla adesso non ci sono più ma se tu
dovessi andare indietro nel tempo e che
tipo di bambino ero
bambino non sono mai stato anche perché
io da 0 a 12 ho vissuto con mia nonna
mio padre mia madre
no ma visti san marco che faccia ce
l'avevano giorno ma era piaciuto signore
che erano i quadri e io ci hanno paura
nasce e quindi da lì il bambino è finito
anche perché sono dovuto subito
diventare grande mi ha detto che mi fa
non a laura no donna scola no ecco che
qua ma ha messo in saccoccia la cosa mi
ha detto scenico fino a 12 anni non line
ma easy ho mai visto e conosciuto perché
un certo punto è arrivato è arrivato
perché ci avevano un'attività all'epoca
loro però per me era una scusa che mi
pare sia sempre trovato era sia
consumatore che che venditore lo capisco
anche perché io sono stato consumatori
per 25 anni quindi io oggi che l'ho
perdonato tra virgolette capisco anche
che non sa è proprio il tempo materiale
per prenderti cura di qualcun altro
anche perché non sei capace non si
abbona piatte curabile se stesso pensa
si sta buono abbiate cura dell'arte di
kart però ho veramente paura di fare un
figlio perché comunque non so se
sentirmi all'altezza o meno ho paura di
fare gli sbagli che ho fatto nei quadri
io vedevo sto monet quando l'ho visto
per la prima volta ho avuto paura e io
vedevo questo amore come il mio idolo io
volevo fare esattamente quello che
facevo a lui ma quindi tu hai vissuto
con tua nonna fino a dove fino a 12 anni
e il rapporto con teheran atom era la
nonna e mia zia erano mio padre e mia
madre tra virgolette odio mamme perché
amate come ne vale via oggi ancora vivo
nella casa che che sono cresciuto con
mia nonna quando veniva mio padre che
non l'ho mai visto io mi nascondevo
perché mia nonna mi faceva fare se che a
scuola e medicina acuto padre mettete di
entrare armario e io per nascondiamo di
entrare mario quando ero piccolo no
quindi anche complice poi purtroppo
quando sono cresciuto facevo molto abuso
di droga e le cose ci siamo anche
lasciati piuttosto male con mia nonna e
quando è morta diciamo che non gli sono
stato vicino come avresti voluto come
dove e quando parli del fatto che c'è
stato questo allontanamento dice che c'è
stato un litigio dovuto anche diciamo
magari al fatto che la droga ti porta un
pochino ad avere un altro tipo di
atteggiamento cioè appena cocaina
trasformava io nasco come un violento io
io ero un violento fino a qualche anno
fa perché appunto avevo questo gruppo è
noi per l'affresco altri perché davanti
nasce prima mancassero proprio non fatti
ci sta pure un coro a noi della partita
non ce ne frega un cazzo scontri sconti
di scorte andate per far east e solo
solo solo botte non la ama e quindi
prima prima di prepararsi a tutto ciò
magari david 23 bottarelle di 34 bere e
andare a fare sconti capito che oggi io
non lo farei mai più però all'epoca vi
dico la verità c'è un'adrenalina che
manco quando metti dentro una banca cioè
la stessa adrenalina poi mischia la
cocaina mischiata all'alcol che potevo
dire prima volta in cui ti sei drogato
invece mi sono drogata 13 anni a
pasquetta praticamente stavamo
raggiungendo un mio amico e andammo in
un paese fuori roma a un certo punto io
ero proprio al di fuori di tutto ma che
ne so che stanno a fà svuota sta cosa
inizia a schiacciarla ha certo punto
mentre stava arrivando a me il tributo
io dico ma che tipo fa le fabbricante
procura mamma dentro e tira forte io ho
fatto
verità purtroppo è piaciuta la droga se
ti piace ha detto male per tutta la vita
se non ti piace che il tuo fisico e la
tua mente hanno di certo se è fortunato
tu hai familiarità con tutte le
tipologie di droghe giusto quasi tutto
immagino che comunque ti capitavano a di
vedere uno specchio di una realtà più
pulita no io su cui sono cresciuto
proprio invece in un contesto
completamente pulita da questo molto
campestre cioè non c'è la droga c'era
proprio lavoro gioco tu hai mai fatto un
confronto rispetto magari a uno stile di
vita uno stile di crescita più lineare
prima solito il confronto
quando due mesi ha drogato a 13 anni il
confronto non hai nemmeno tempo di farlo
perché perché poi quando fai uso di
sostanze e dentro casa vedono
ormai si è targata così si dice no ma
quando veniva invece un altro bambino o
un ragazzino che sereno se ne veniva in
motorino che ti diceva io da prova dal
nuoto il primo istinto è più forte
quindi hai avuto un momento di rabbia ma
certo ma mio padre calcola che l'ho
perdonato qualche anno fa io ti ripeto
ci ho 42 anni ma quando si perdona una
persona in questo senso non è che si
perdona di città o da ho perdonato
mentalmente tu vai talmente a lavorare
con te stesso con con tutti gli errori
che ci ha portato a fare quell infame di
persona e comunque però anche tu stesso
li hai fatti no ho perso del tempo
perché se tu vuoi uscire da questo
meccanismo di cose ne è uscita solo un
giorno di specchi etici basta ho finito
nelle casse rideva gli dico che devo
scommettere un fascio bling ed è da lì
in qualche modo ho gestito la mia vita
ho cercato di gestirla uno che cosa
quando è successo perché ti faccio un
parallelo con me che capisco che è
diverso però io ho un app che mi dice da
quanto non fumo sigarette e io infatti
dico sempre che nel mio caso io sono un
fumatore che non fuma non sono un ex
fumatore sono una persona che ogni
giorno a fine pranzo ti avvolge ray in
una cartina che acer è i capelli e
fumerei dai tuoi talloni capito per cui
immagino sia comunque una battaglia
costante ma cos'è che anche partito
invece talmente alla parte che io ho
bisogno la cocaina ti sera io ti notte
ma la sogno invece di sognare le donne
che bisogna cocaina rega quando fai uso
di sostanze di questa merda questo è il
diavolo in persona tutta la droga il
diavolo in persona tu sei circondato da
negatività e tutte le persone che
incontri per strada ai bar in discoteca
sono tutte persone negative che invece
di limbo brasilia ci hai fatto a una
mistica avuta pizzicata via il sacchetto
e te ha capito
ok quelli non sono amici quelli sono
pezzi di merda no io sono stato
fortunato perché era stato come un
meccanismo di un orologio come sia
incastro il lavoro l'amore la positività
allora gli arabi via più un libro ma dal
veder lecce quantistica dico ma che
cazzo la legge matese la positività
delle persone la
positività del mondo no il carcere mi è
servito poi dipende come devo fare
perché risolve una scuola di di reati il
carcere no magari enti camminatore esci
spacciatore e appena sono uscito ho
detto basta in un giorno nella vita che
fa per me non è una proprio dalla vita
che voglio un po di difficoltà c'erano
perché stavano bianca ha rovinato c'ha
una lira però mi sentivo un uomo diverso
è una scelta che è partita per te stesso
o più mossa dagli altri nel senso che tu
prima dicevi c'era un periodo in cui
l'amore le cose quindi magari nella mia
testa di c l'ho fatto anche per le
persone che mi stavano vicino c'è il
motore quale è stato quando pensi di
farlo soprattutto per gli altri ma
capito un cazzo perché ricaschi subito
quando il cervello di dice che e ti
parte interiormente una cosa che tu fai
per te stesso e io perché ho vinto
perché ho iniziato a volermi bene ha
svegliata mattino faceva tutte le
mattine 8 e le 9 di mattina allucinato
quando in cornici a svegliarsi la
mattina fresco tutto riposato bello va
in palestra da allen e ti rendi conto
troppo tardi ma noi già sono passati 25
anni capisci che ti voglio dire io ne
siano a 14 15 anni arriva da 42 mo so
tornato indietro e mocio 15 anni a me la
gente mi diceva come dei resti ecco
adesso io ci ho vent'anni come non è
solo la storia di tempo restia a
qualsiasi ragazzo trovare infatti per
farci capire no sei nato uomo può essere
cresciuto bambino
ma mi posso togliere gli organi abbiamo
molte di poesia al bello che spesso una
cosa sacrosanta però ha
davvero io ti chiedo qual è se ti
ricordi
una cosa che hai visto da piccolo e che
ti rimasta impressa diciamo in maniera
molto forte in negativo cioè c'è
qualcosa che tu dici guarda immaginati
che quando io avevo otto anni ho
testimoniato questo quando andavamo a
prendere perché qui si parlava di chili
di cocaina no io stavo dietro quadre
cucco la moto era talmente di quello che
mi addormentavo perché di solito quando
sai ho un padre di famiglia co.co.co un
ragazzino di a fronte fermano e allora
io venivo utilizzato come tra virgolette
come si dice ma spartoo va a bra è
bravissimo il passepartout ha capito che
trovi e poi negli anni dico a tutelare
di cotone io invece restato che ha messi
ibra di mezzo di ingrassato capito
inattiva gara sempre con va certo perché
come un nuovo fermano mai poi ero bello
come il sole così capelli a caschetto
sembrava nino d'angelo una virgola e
quello è stato il processo che ti ha
portato a perdere cioè per donare una
cosa del genere comunque deve essere un
processo mentale forte
il processo è stato talmente complesso
negli anni io ho sofferto talmente dato
io mi drogavo e piangevo perché non era
una cosa che che dovevo fare io mi sono
trovato per l'altro ho fatto per i reati
per l'arte perché a 13 anni ma che voce
io su youtube e social a parte dico
queste cose qui dico che io io ce l'ho
fatta ciao sono fatto cenno ma quando su
200 messaggi che riceva giorno 180 soldi
insulti a me viene da ridere però perché
qui a fine mese rido quando si fanno i
conti poi le sponsorizzazioni e tutto
quello a me insultare me l'importante è
che se ne parli perché chi ti insulta è
quello che io appena metto la storia
dopo un secondo e mezzo la val vedere
ciò talmente una corazza dentro ma non
voglio dire che sono talmente forte
perché dopo non vorrei essere scambiato
per o su sono talmente forte giornata le
personalità con carattere che fa paura
che ma rimbalza tutto io quando vedo le
cose che magari per la 100 a me ho visto
cento volte se
potessi incontrare il tè da bambino cosa
gli enti meco correre tutto dico che
quando porto io sognavo da man mano via
commedia il segreto di tutto il mio
riscatto è il massimiliano bambino io
quando sto a casa ciò alice che torna da
casa io mi nascondo sotto il letto è lì
c'era della campania la gente riconosce
solo sue cronaca nera e purtroppo che
oscilla sui giornali video con tre
guardie ma il massimiliano nuovo io ce
l'ho fatta grazie come diceva prima
michele a massimiliano bambino quello
che tu mi hai detto è il segreto quindi
diciamo che hai perso un occhio per
imparare a vederti in maniera diversa
non sono quelle cose un po che ho perso
un occhio perché ho preso una voce alla
faccia ecco quello è così come può il
tavoli diga foranea classiche finiva mai
stato i diavoli
litigare
ma che non te lo dico city girava e può
essere stato un triplo e terminale può
essersi dedicata però spetta io ho
sempre difeso anche a scuola no i più
deboli ovviamente no io io andavo a far
covato quelli che erano preoccupati dei
miei perché sino al facile no io andavo
a circa quelli che entrai brno è libera
ma proprio perché mi piaceva proprio un
giorno ho preso ho preso una 16 il culo
della crs no facile a esser pomodoro
hanno lasciato esplodere scelti dopo ha
certo punto tutto oscuro dica covato
stavo talmente fatto che io all'inizio
non ho sentito niente poi dopo a casa di
non è successo ci vedo più ci vedo più
ma gira non c'era una macchina che stava
vola sopra del centro nell'occhio ma
ormai era passato in secondo piano come
vado a far vedere ma hanno staccato
tutore di naruto
cornea tutto chiaro chiaro chiaro come
ti sei posto invece così per entrare
all'interno di un argomento caro ad
alcuni di noi nei confronti dell'amore
perché tu parli di alice in maniera
veramente bella è una ragazza pur a una
ragazza che
non ha grilli per la testa e la vedevo
che comunque dio ma questa compatto come
me ma che cazzo che fa quest'asta perde
tempo invece lei una volta mi disse ciò
i brividi anche se non si vedono perché
non scioperi mi disse io ho visto quel
quello che gli altri non hanno nemmeno
minimamente
pensato che tu fossi e quindi ho detto
che qualche mettetevi finalmente muove
più capisci che ti voglio dire lei
andata oltre a tutto ma quindi
cioè le tue relazioni quando eri
ragazzino con le ragazze o come erano
come gli sto chiedendo ancora scusa come
dice volevo proporre se ogni tanto par a
citofonare gli dico oscurità chiedo
scusa per tutto quello che ti ho fatto
perché la cocaina ti ti ti toglie le
emozioni ti toglie tutto chi togliere
quando stai fatto e tu stai lucido io so
su un altro pianeta io non posso sta mai
vicino a te che tu stai lucido capito
perché io sto a 8 step avanti a te anzi
tu style 8 stato avanti a me io sto
dietro invece io sono sposato e
divorziato
acqua con acciaio un giorno era venerdì
io ho detto esco vola compresi che
dettano stimava un fumo tabasco se
spesso rientrato martedì sarà lucina
capito che le cose così che ne ha
portati con sé sbagliato e giusto nel
momento in cui non stavi facendo mano
vallo sbagliato è giusto perché a casa
mia vigeva la legge che alle c'eravamo
noi quindi fatto era tutto giusto quello
che facevamo noi è paradossale questa
cosa ma il video che mi ha fatto
diventare famoso che penso che abbiate
visto pabst tutto il mondo è quello con
3 the guardian o io o contro 20
guardiano io ci ho sempre avuta che
riguardi quelli voraci fa nel lavoro
loro per 1.400 euro al mese noi comunque
li vedevamo come nemici numeri uno e
comunque non ci facevamo con associate
facevamo vedere in volgare la nostra
rigiravo col team max mentre senza casco
ma come fermavano facevo come me pare
quindi il giusto e lo sbagliato era noi
è solo creiamo
cosa era successo all'interno di quel
video purtroppo erano quattro giorni che
stavo sveglio c'era una manifestazione
di casapound all'epoca perché c'erano
dei rumeni che si stavano accoltellando
durante la settimana e abbiamo fatto più
di qualche morto e io mi sono affacciato
e ho visto queste forze dell'ordine che
giravano il cervello mi chiamo ha detto
che quella era casa mia alice dove non
sa io sono sceso chiama dio lo ha
fischiato venite qui ha detto come
solleva la maglietta ma quando si sono
avvicinati dicono che faccio
ormai ce sto però se tu vedi il video
loro non mi hanno toccato quel che loro
mi hanno rispettato in quel frangente
perché lì scattavano a scacchiera
succedeva al panico perché io
apprezzo mi portavo e adesso che
rapporto hai con la legge ma con la
legge adesso si fermano se fame e voi
dovete passare dei brasiliani famose una
foto anche uno dei motivi insomma che
per cui siamo contentissimi averti qui è
proprio il fatto che la tua una storia
anche di rivincita rinascita cambiamento
il karma fa un giro enorme un certo
punto ti ha bussato nel momento in cui
che hanno fatto questo video mi arriva
il mio il mio video della polizia dico
brasilia stagira stupido se virale stai
dappertutto è che mi sono trovato un
profilo da 90 mila follower dico io devo
sfruttarlo è in tutto e per tutto questo
profilo quindi il profilo quello
quell'altro ha fatto sì che capisci che
ti voglio dire poi con ad un'altra c'era
un'altra strada impropriamente che sarei
io poi essendo che so 30mila per strada
e io appena metà in occasione che mi
attacco e non me la faccio sfuggire che
ho fatto di como come ho sfruttato suo
profilo e ho iniziato a dare i messaggi
positivi ai ragazzi non vedono gati è
nata scola non fa di reati mosso a 2 60
ma come se c'era 600.000 perché c'è un
profilo di una bomba a mano e ho
cominciato a sponsorizzare io oggi mi
ritengo un influenza no perché a parte
va da roma a milano a napoli dove ad
ovada a genova
grazie però soprattutto a quel video la
prima di tutto ciò io non è che ero
proprio sconosciuto a roma parlo avevo
un gruppo ultras allo stadio è riunito
nel sette alla cronaca nera certo sono
ancora ok allora mucci dico un'altra
cosa io facevo i recuperi notti voi
recuperi crediti ma no quelli legali che
te vi stavate botte melevisione quando
andava fuori questi recuperi non li ho
mai fatti a persone perbene non sono mai
stato un bullo se uno avesse detto
guarda c'è stata cristina che ci deve
dare 60 mila euro ma scende da cristina
rivali perché io darei donne ce vado
parli molto dell'importanza economica
dell'enorme valore concreto che questo
cambiamento di vita teate ha concesso no
tu parli spesso anche del valore morale
e del fatto che i soci alti hanno aperto
la mente hai parlato del fatto che ti
sei del cancellato dei tatuaggi diciamo
abbastanza forti cos'è che è successo in
che modo invece ti hanno aiutato ecco i
social da questo punto di vista sono
stati importanti perché perché io a un
certo punto mi sono visto aprire delle
strade cioè io mi sono messo a tavoli
con michele santoro vauro
prima stavo col patata con bruschetta
con scivola invece di rho michele
santoro non c'è qualcosa c'è qualcosa
che sta cambiando non è che mi sono
tolto certi tatuaggi per paura degli
insulti delle persone che mi dicono sei
lifar dito senio fame parliamo di
tatuaggi di estrema destra molto estremo
io ci avevo mussolini queste cose qua
quando te le vai a tatuare quando tu ce
l'hai con te stesso ce l'hai con il
mondo e dici io milano mussolini vediamo
chi mi viene a rompere il cazzo me dice
capito mi aveva sfida bravissimo che
cazzo ma diceva niente però per dirsi no
ceroni giudici non era tanto un'idea
un'ideologia la prima gara da prima
prima prima trattato assi mussolini a
meno mamma fegatoso vagni è vivo la
spagna vede come mussolini antonio ora
non mi è mai fregato niente adesso io mi
sono fatto tutto nero non per coprire
perché proprio mi piace questo stile qui
però ho cominciato a riflettere
e capire no dico dove vado con questo
tipo di tatuaggi ormai è proponibile una
cosa del genere anche perché voglio dire
quel tipo di vitali non l'ha con due o
più e poi c'è un massiccio e un altro
massimiliano quindi via e ho cominciato
a togliere tutto quanto è stata
complicata perché c'era avevo talmente
tanti che ho dovuto coprire gran parte
del mio corpo ha visto un sacco di serie
tv ambientate nel carcere prigione io se
nostra curioso di quello di sapere com'è
la vita e poi volevo chiederti se hai
fatto qualche tatuaggio quando eri
quelli che ho io faccio quasi 2 kg fatti
debito ma è la cosa della lacrima e ci
danno un botto quell'attentato perché se
la lacrima piena e omicidio la mia
sfumata a dio perché sono stato kutcher
e dicevano cavo spara da uno poi non ho
avuto le prove 15 avevo tentato omicidio
estorsione e porto abusivo d'armi e
quando sono stato dentro mi sono fatto
alla prima però il 90 per cento di chi
si tatua queste cose insomma code di un
san marco urbana certo una mela al
supermercato
io pensavo invece fosse piango perché
comunque sono in carcere no no no ci
fosse questa insegnano molto bene queste
serie
racconta volevo chiederti come
nella cioè cosa si mangia allora è mai
chiesto cosa
curiosa allora senti spiego quando hai
possibilità economica tt permettere il
carcere di fare la spesa al supermercato
col carrello certo tu c'hai una lista e
diciamo carta igienica da violini banane
mele pere tu comunque mangi quello che
cucini to sono una delle poche persone
che ti dice che io al carcere sono stato
bene perché è partita la mia redenzione
dal carcere perché se se tutti i file
carcere a cazzo di cane è chic e sempre
cede prima io ho ragionato con me stesso
io ho imparato a questa questa è una
cosa che ci tengo a dirla perché è il
fulcro della mia rinascita io dentro al
carcere ho iniziato a vedere un uomo
massimiliano perché dicevo ma io ma qui
dentro giustizia ma che c'entrano quando
non ci sta con la testa se tu spari a
1.34 giorni che ti riprendi elice c'è il
braccio di è il settimo si chiamano
quando quando in cornici a ragionare di
che ho fatto c'è il 90 per cento di chi
sta carcerato quando passò tutti i
drogati mano fanno i reati quando rigi
c'è chi ha ammazzato delle persone certo
ci rovini la vita perché stanno di fatto
non ci ricordi quello che hai fatto
quando ti stai riprendendo share
omicidio sue spalle di facciata anni c'è
ed è serio vi nato ma non ci sono le non
è diviso tipo in fazioni quelli spaccio
omicidio non sono ci sono c'è il
precauzionale che quello di infame
quello dei pedofili o maltrattare donne
e bambini di chi fa la spia e
quant'altro e poi ci sono i comuni i
comuni volti la gente come una vera che
comunque per quanto sei stato sono stato
due anni 83 di diverse contrini quando
sei un personaggio che che conta tra
virgolette tutto anche dentro al carcere
un topo e sceglie mai omesso scelto
quello che ho detto mica stavano uomini
e donne che dice io ho detto a bergolo
volevo giovane perché sono tutti sotto
nino la maggior parte sono tutti i
sassoni che chi prende la terapia a
terapia sono tutti gli stili medicinali
per dormire no anzi vomitano addosso si
fisciano addosso quindi chi entra che
giovane dopo 34 giorni si riprende
e subito operativo perché lì ti devi
dare dei compiti io faccio io cucino tu
fai piatti fire bagno capito ci stanno
queste invece che stanno tutte le giorno
fatti se poi dentro entra tutto cocaina
eroina fumo intra tutto inutile che
grazie alle guardie grazie alle guardie
noi non pagava me guardie quelle
distorte gli davo 500 euro e faceva
entra tutto quello che volevo a me e
quindi complessi ma qua abbastanza la
francese dovesse ma quindi come era la
perché io la cella me la immagino
proprio a 2 poi dipende dai carceri ci
sono c'è la 2c alla 4 cella 6 stanzoni
carriera noi dentro il bagno dentro la
cella non la doccia però la doccia
comune come passare le giornate mi
alzavo alle otto e mezza colazione alle
nove e mezza prima no perché sotto c'era
la palestra andavamo in palestra
io tornavo su mi facevo la doccia
iniziava a cucinare quindi poi ti ti
chiudono all'una ci vedevamo tutti ed
era sessione uomini e donne dopo le
quattro di aprono e sta fino alle sei
libero aspetta se il corridoio domanda
cucina vi comunico la mia rho ix che
cortellino continua a portare l'ici ai
coltelli decarta quelli là del e quindi
è certo certo anche con diciamo vari
attenzione l'arma si fa un attimo
secondi a 100 in cella poi fumare anzi
si può fare tutto lì lì si può fare
tutto quello che vuoi non sai è certo
che si può fare mentre invece una
un'altra il sesso sesso
ai 30 anni di carcere avrai tre
dipendenti so dietologia forza devo fare
occhio poi ritirare su questo
in realtà ho una prima domanda banale
milita con po al tuo passato no che per
detto nell'infanzia ci avevate questa
cosa quasi
mitologica che ognuno avrà un epiteto
detto er il brasiliano quale sarebbe il
nostro epiteto tu sei un genio
allora a piace alla pensato ok
genio incompreso ok sanità come questa
cosa da sé la pezzata genere comprese
fra lui e lui è lui è quello sì il poeta
oppure
profonda meglio il profondo genio
incompreso ringrazio ce l'ha pensato di
andata alla grande insomma sono
contentissimo io so per ora
l'aspetta riporta sul tenore un secondo
vorrei riprendere un attimo la figura di
tua nonna perché per me i nonni sono
tipo
anch'io sono cresciuto con i nonni cioè
per me mia nonna mio nonno sono stati
dei riferimenti enormi non è tu hai
detto che comunque è un po di rimpianto
non ha rispetto al fatto che magari
nell'ultima parte c'è stata
un'incomprensione graziata da tutta
l'allucinazione che sta vivendo
se tu dovessi dire qualcosa oggi a tua
nonna no perché sei una persona
completamente diversa cosa gli diresti
tanto che la ringrazio di tutto quello
che hanno fatto comunque mi ha cresciuto
io penso che se fossi cresciuto fino a
30 anni con mia nonna forse era un
avvocato che cazzo ti avevo studiato ed
evoluto e devo tutto quanto è il mio
rammarico diciamo che non l'ho salutata
come dovevo nel senso che comunque io ho
rubato di cose dentro casa quindi stava
parla proprio da vanessa proprio capisci
che ti voglio dire e quindi questo il
rammarico più grande è che comunque non
l'ho salutata come dovevo lollo servitù
per cambiare ma
quando
ho portato un po di tristezza il poeta
lascia la mazzata e ora
come ci si era così invece no secondo me
è un bel modo anche per finire perché è
vero che siamo feroce ma allo stesso
tempo dietro ogni leone si nasconde un
gattino
un'ultima cosa che ti senti dire siamo
arrivati proprio alla fine c'è qualcosa
che fino ad adesso non è detto vuoi
ribadire un messaggio per guidare
qualsiasi cosa di non fare reati di
andare a scuola a chi ci sta ascoltando
a chi ci ascolterà e io gli dico
comunque di andare a scuola di studiare
perché è una delle cose più importanti e
poi ci aiuta ad aprire la mente come
poche cose che ti aiutano praticamente a
questi ragazzi a queste ragazze gli dico
di percorrere la propria vita e di
percorrere i propri sogni perché tanto
ciava voluti prima o poi lega tanto il
karma gilas se siamo persone buone torna
adulto a destinazione questo è quello
che mi sento di dire grazie massimina si
alza voi ragazzi tiriamo le somme di
questa puntata tutto torni con gli
occhiali che figata
hai un sacco poi io sono stracciati
piace sa cosa per le cose del carcere
però da dire che io vorrei fare tipo un
periodo di carcere ma che mai e chiede
due consigli che magari mi fa entrare fa
fronte c'è un ora per dire loro alla
criminalità
finiamola pulita
no di carcere per vedere un po come è
così speriamo sarà antropologici euro il
video e tipo voga avete presente wall
come e mi fa tutto il mondo anche lady
gaga quando fa telephone certo io devo
ammettere un errore però perché io cioè
sono veramente cerco sempre di non avere
pregiudizio con le persone che incontro
ammetto che io avevo un pregiudizio ma
non tanto rispetto al passato di questa
persona ma rispetto alla sua attitudine
di raccontare non una risoluzione e
invece guarda una cosa che noto tanto
nelle persone la scelta delle parole e
lui ha avuto un modo di dire guarda c'è
stato un momento in cui ti ha detto con
la droga davanti otto passi davanti a te
poesia cose che non ho detto una
cavolata ero otto passi indietro devo
dire ammetto una mia colpa di aver avuto
un pregiudizio ma esco comunque da
questa chiacchierata con
è chiaramente una persona molto lontana
no anche dal mio modo di pensare così
tanto però comunque ci vedo dentro un
messaggio un bel seme fare un bel sì
e parlando come l'insieme io invece in
carcere avrei voluto essere ha detto a
le saponette non so che dire e chiudiamo
la puntata ciao michele ti ringrazio i
ragazzi ovviamente grazie a tutti quanti
per averci seguito e la prossima puntata
vedrà come ospite franco candy un
ufologo che è stato rapito due volte due
volte dagli alieni per cui a parlarci
della sua esperienza ma soprattutto a
raccontarci di come si fa a portare
avanti una propria convinzione quando
tutti ti danno contro da noi feroci e
tutto ragazze e ragazzi un graffio con
grazia con grazia
[Musica]